Kid 1: Whoa.
Did you know that so much
plastic is drifting out in
the ocean that it has
made a giant island?
Two times the size of Texas!
You think I could, like, make a
resort on it...hey, what’s that?
Kid 2: It’s this old video
game system that dad insisted
made him a “hardcore gamer”.
I’m pretty sure it
just makes him old.
Kid 1: What’s it called?
Kid 2: Super Mallio Brothers.
Hey, it’s not working!
Kid 1: Precise electronic
that would surely fry if the
slightest bit of
liquid meets it?
Try blowing on it.
Kid 2: That logic seems sound.
Mallio: Ok LuiVC.
Let’s go save the Princess.
Oh mamma mia
Princess, you’re
supposed to start in the castle.
Polly Mer: Not this time Mallio.
Now I’m leading the adventure.
LuiVC, that demotes you from
sidekick to third wheel.
LuiVC: Ohh, Mamma Mia.
LuiVC lose!
Polly Mer: Stop it.
We have bigger concerns.
Bisphenowser is up
to no good again.
Mallio: Oh no.
What is he doing now?
Polly Mer: He’s decided to
build himself a new castle,
made entirely out of plastic,
without any concern about what
that will do to
the environment.
You know how he does it.
Tons of hard plastic spikes,
molten plastic moats,
go-kart track, all that stuff.
Mallio: But how does using
plastic hurt the environment?
Polly Mer: Wait, don’t you guys
know anything about plastic?
LuiVC: Ummm...When you
grab it, you become
invincible for a short time?
Polly Mer: Nope,
that’s the stars.
LuiVC: Oh.
Then no.
Polly Mer: Of course not.
What did I expect from
two guys who constantly
hit bricks with their heads?
Anyway, you guys need
to know everything about
plastic to defeat Bisphenowser.
Let’s start at Bisphenowser’s
plastic factory.
LuiVC: Hey, what are they doing?
Polly Mer: That’s
how plastic is made.
Fossil fuels such as crude
oil and natural gas are heated,
causing them to break down into
small molecules called monomers.
These monomers can
be combined to form
long chains called polymers.
And these polymers are plastics!
LuiVC: But I thought
that fossil fuels are used
to produce energy?
Polly Mer: That’s also right.
Even this factory runs on
energy from fossil fuels, and
all this use of fossil
fuels greatly contributes to
pollution in our environment!
Mallio: LuiVC, we’ve
got to stop this!
Polly Mer: Good job.
Lets go now.
LuiVC: Aaahhh! What’s
with all the stink clouds?
Polly Mer: That’s all dioxin
Boollution, and with everything
Bisphenowser has been doing,
it’s getting really bad.
LuiVC: Dioxin boolution?
What’s that?
Polly Mer: Dioxins are highly
toxic chemicals released into
the atmosphere during the
production of the plastic
polyvinylchloride,
also known as PVC.
Dioxins can cause
many health problems.
Mallio: Let’s
get out of here.
I think that I would
rather fight Bisphenowser
than breathe in this Boolution.
LuiVC: Whoa, that’s
a lot of plastic.
What is it all doing here?
Polly Mer: This must be
where Bisphenowser is
disposing of his plastic waste.
Mallio: You mean he’s just
gonna leave it out here?
Polly Mer: Most likely, yes.
Many commonly used plastics are
not biodegradable, meaning that
they don’t break down over time.
Instead, they are going
to stay here forever.
LuiVC: What are those
mushrooms doing?
Polly Mer: Bacteria and fungi,
such as those mushrooms,
are decomposers, meaning that
they can break down matter.
Some fungi and bacteria, not
that particular mushroom, can
even decompose a small amount
of some types of plastics–
but it’s not enough.
Mallio: So mushrooms
are really helpful?
Polly Mer: Yes, and thats
why you guys should stop
eating so many of them.
Mallio: Well at least
plastics can’t do any harm
by just sitting out here
Polly Mer: Actually, they can.
Toxic chemicals can accidentally
leak out of the plastics and
into the landfills and
eventually into the groundwater.
LuiVC: But what’s
toxic in plastic?
Polly Mer: Chemicals
like BPA and phthalates.
BPA is used to make clear
polycarbonate plastics and
epoxy plastics that coat
the inside of food cans.
BPA is an endocrine-disruptor,
meaning that it can interfere
with the hormones in our body.
And phthalates are chemicals
added to plastics to improve
flexibility and durability.
Like BPA, Some phthalates
can also cause problems to
the endocrine system, while
others can cause cancer.
Once these chemicals enter the
ground water, they can be easily
absorbed by plants,
and they can also
enter rivers, lakes, and oceans.
Come on, I'll show you.
LuiVC: What’s wrong with
those purple animals?
Polly Mer: These animals have
been getting their water and
food from this BPA
contaminated pond,
just downhill from the landfill.
Just like in humans, BPA
contamination will cause
reproductive problems
in plants and animals.
And this gets worse
higher up the food chain.
First, small organisms called
plankton absorb tiny amounts of
the toxins from the water.
Then when fish eat hundreds
of these plankton, they absorb
the chemicals in each one.
This magnification
process happens again
when the animals eat these fish.
Once in the organism, the toxin
is very hard to get rid of-
so it just accumulates
inside the organism.
Mallio: Oh no!
What should we do
about the landfill?
LuiVC: We could
burn the plastic!
Polly Mer: Actually,
that’s a bad idea.
Burning plastic greatly pollutes
the environment by releasing
toxic chemicals
into the atmosphere.
Mallio: Well then, we better
go stop Bisphenowser.
LuiVC: Oh no, they’re choking!
Mallio: Look at
all this plastic.
Polly Mer: Yes, many plastics,
especially plastic pellets,
often end up in oceans.
These pellets are especially
harmful to fish, because they
are easily mistaken for food.
Once eaten, the pellets
block their digestive system
and they die.
Mallio: We’ve got to
defeat Bisphenowser.
LuiVC: Hey, what’s
over there in the ocean?
Mallio: It looks like a
floating pile of trash.
Polly Mer: That's
actually all plastic.
Every year, 8 million tons of
plastic is put into the ocean.
That's equivalent to 5
plastic bags for every foot of
coastline in the world.
Bisphenowser: Who dares
enter my plastic kingdom?
Mallio: Ehhh...
It’s-a-me, Mallio.
LuiVC: And LuiVC!
Mallio: I feel like you
are borrowing this from
someone else...
Look at
Bisphenowser’s health bar!
LuiVC: Oh! It looks like
Bisphenowser has been
poisoned by all that plastic!
Polly Mer: Bisphenowser probably
ingested the BPA, dioxins, and
phthalates that the plastic
released into the air and water.
LuiVC: That did it!
Polly Mer: Sure, but those
chemicals in the air, water, and
ground will take
longer to get rid of.
Even a small impact from plastic
pollution can cause a large
problem in the environment.
Mallio: What can we do to help?
Polly Mer: You should avoid
using plastic when possible.
Bring a reusable grocery bag,
use your own takeout containers,
and carry a reusable
bottle for drinks.
LuiVC: And if you have
to use plastic, make sure
you know where to recycle it.
Polly Mer: Yup So what do
you guys want to do now?
Mallio: Do you want
to play tennis?
LuiVC: No
Mallio: How about go-karts?
LuiVC: Nah
Mallio: What about soccer?
LuiVC: No
LuiVC: Let’s
just throw a party!